the media asked whether it's time to
repeal the Second Amendment Democrats
say the NRA is responsible for the
Florida school shooting and Republicans
shoot down a bunch of immigration
proposals we'll talk about all of it I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
obviously the tragedy of the Parkland
school shooting is still on everyone's
mind and every time there's a massive
shooting like this whether it's Las
Vegas or whether it is Sandy Hook we now
go into a predictable cycle of outrage
where folks say things that are
ridiculous they impute motives to other
people that are ridiculous and then
those people fire back and it becomes
highly irritating well we're gonna talk
a little bit about some of those
arguments today Jimmy Kimmel of course
jumped into the fray so we'll have to
deconstruct what he says I'll stop
deconstructing Jim Jimmy Kimmel on
politics when he stops talking about
politics on a late-night show we are
also going to be jumping into a column
that was written by Bret Stevens a year
ago but it's now being passed around the
internet again about repealing the
Second Amendment we'll get to all of
that but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at quit so when it
comes to health brushing your teeth is
one of the most important parts of your
day actually they've connected gum
health to heart health believe it or not
and that is why it is imperative that
you brush right right when you have a
manual toothbrush those things just
don't work as well as a nice electric
toothbrush but those electric
toothbrushes take forever to charge and
then it's hard to travel with them
because you have to bring the charger
with you well that's where qyp comes in
is the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amount of
vibrations into a slimmer design and a
fraction of the cost of bulkier
traditional electric brushes and guiding
pulses alert you want to switch sides so
you make sure that you're brushing the
right amounts of time and that makes it
effortless quit balls it comes with a
mount that suctions right to your mirror
on sticks to use as a cover for hygienic
travel anywhere whether it's gonna be in
your gym bag or on your carry-on and
right now best of all they have a
subscription plan that refreshes your
brush on a dentist recommended schedule
delivering new brush heads every three
months for just five bucks including
free shipping worldwide so you never
have to worry about when you're going to
replace the brush has you've been using
yours for seven months it's disgusting
already but you forgot about it you
can't remember when you last put on a
brush head
well now clip ships them to you every
month so these are being replaced on a
regular basis clip is backed by a
network of over 10,000 dental
professionals we's it in the Shapiro
household and it starts at just 25 bucks
so if you go to get quick comm slash
Shapiro right now you get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at get quip comm slash up hero
again that's GE t qu IP comm slash
apparel get quip comm slash up hero go
ahead and check that out well worth the
time and money okay so the fallout from
the from the shoot
a couple of days ago continues as well
it should and again it's the circular
argument that has become highly
irritating to everybody involved in
which people on the left scream do
something people on the right say well
what would you have us do and then
people on the Left say well if you're
even asking that question it means you
don't want to do something that seems
like the cycle of logic that is applied
here so Jimmy Kimmel of course is the
leader in in being the sort of emotional
the emotional avatar for the left so he
goes on his show last night and he of
course talks about the shooting and
pushes hard for gun control with his
usual caveats and freak-outs about the
NRA another senseless shooting this time
in a high school in parkland Florida
were a gunman a former student opened
fire yesterday again 17 lives have been
lost more than a dozen people are
hospitalized tell your buddies in
Congress tell Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell and Marco Rubio all the family
men who care so much about their
communities that what we need are laws
real laws that do everything possible to
keep assault rifles out of the hands of
people who are gonna shoot our kids go
on TV and tell them to do that okay go
tell people what to do and what we need
laws and what are these laws gonna be
and you don't leave the Congress works
for us they don't work for the NRA this
is one of the the things that he was
pushing the idea the NRA was responsible
get to that in a minute again all of
this is just designed to make you
believe that Jimmy Kimmel has a plan
Jimmy Kimmel doesn't have a plan people
on the Left don't have a plan and if
they do have a plan it really is to
confiscate guns now the minute that you
say that about people on the Left they
get very upset no no we just want
reasonable gun legislation but then they
can never name what the reasonable dozen
legislation is because if they were to
ban assault rifles the reality is the
vast majority of killings that are done
with guns in the United States are not
with assault rifles assault rifles are
responsible for West murders in the
United States then hands or knives when
when people on the Left say well what if
we would just do better background
checks we have full background checks in
the state of California and that has not
stopped the Isla Vista shooting it did
not stop the San Bernardino shooting
again the problem with these targeted
gun laws is that what people in left
really want if they were honest about
they would say this Piers Morgan when I
was on with him in 2013 he refused to
say it but then he finally came out and
he was honest about what they really
want as a UK style government seizure of
vast amounts of guns that is not going
to happen in the United States they
tried it in Australia they tried a gun
buyback program only 1/3 of all the guns
that were turned in in Australia they
still have a murder rate in Australia
with guns
people are still they'd still gun
buybacks it is illegal to own a gun in
Australia and yet people still owned
guns 2/3 of the people who owned it
before still owned it in the United
States if you were to grandfather in all
of the guns that still are there there
are 300 million guns in the United
States so that would not actually solve
the problem you're talking about because
a lot of the guns that are that are in
hands of people who are going to commit
school shootings in the future are
already in those hands I'd say it
actually have to go around conference
getting guns good luck trying to take
guns away from 42% of the American
public who say 42% of households say
that there's a gun in the house or
there's a gun in my house and the the
the government would have to come to my
house and take it from me I'm not gonna
offer it back in the government buyback
and either as anybody else who owns a
gun those are those programs are wildly
unsuccessful so what the left really is
talking about is full-scale gun
confiscation so along those and you see
that right way at the school vigil
there's that there's a vigil at the
school and this chant broke out no more
guns now I don't know what that's
supposed to mean no more guns are you
gonna take away the ones that people
already have you can take away from from
law-abiding citizens and then CNN the
rest of the media they spend an awful
lot of time bringing on victims of
shootings to talk about what gun policy
should be so CNN featured a grieving
mother I'm never in favor of this by the
way I think that it's always a mistake
to have grieving people talk about
policy because I don't think that your
grief is relevant to the policy
considerations at issue you do not have
the added legitimacy it's a form of
emotional identity politics you do not
have added legitimacy on the topic
because as a blank write as this is what
Steven Pinker it suggests his identity
politics he has a white man as a black
woman as a grieving mother as soon as
you say that a grieving mother has more
moral legitimacy to speak on gun control
than somebody who studied the issue all
their life then you are throwing away
reason in favor of emotion in any case
here's this mother and I obviously have
nothing but sympathy for the mom and
that's why CNN is putting her on the air
you say what can you do
schools what can you do you can do a lot
this is not fair our families our
children go to school I just spent the
last two hours putting the burial
arrangements for my daughter's funeral
miss 14 president Trump
please do something yeah obviously it is
horrifying to watch minutes it's just
terrible to watch this this grieving
mother but when she's screaming at Trump
to do something what the question is
what Trump is supposed to do the
President of the United States doesn't
have unilateral authority to seize guns
in the United States the President of
the United States does not have
unilateral authority but even metal
detectors which which is by the way a
proposal I agree with on school grounds
I think that security should be up at
all schools as I said yesterday having
armed guards at every school is not a I
failed to understand why this is even
remotely controversial but the reason
that's the bigger question is not about
the mom I understand where the mom is
coming from everyone with a heart
understands where the mom is coming from
the question is why is CNN spending
airtime on this and the reason that CNN
is spending airtime on this is because
CNN wants to manipulate viewers into
responding emotionally to an issue that
actually requires thought and and reason
as opposed to an issue that requires
emotional response
you notice that CNN never does this by
the way with victims of terror attacks
and then will never go to victims of
terror attacks after there is an ilanic
terror attack for example and they won't
have the victim of the terror attacks
family go on TV and say we need a travel
ban at CNN we'll never do that because
that doesn't agree with CNN's agenda the
point here is that it's exploitative for
the media to put grieving people on
television simply in order to make a
certain political point it's something I
object to generally it's something I
object to on the specific level and I
think that it's it's something that
really needs to stop and again they were
doing this with students as well see and
then put a student on TV to talk about
why this is somehow on Rick Scott's
Rather's MSNBC doing this well you know
again it's a slew of emotion it's anger
it's fear and confusion it's grief and
I've just been trying to channel those
all together and into some sort of mad
inspiration I'm trying to get the
message out that it is important to
grieve but it's also
to make sure the bad guys feel this
natural and make sure everybody knows
that their votes count on this it's my
stupid lief that the blood of those 17
people is on rich hands okay so some
some how it is it's not rich Scott its
Rick Scott and somehow the blood of the
people who died in parklands on Rick
Scott's hands why is it on Rick Scott's
hands when it when a nutcase
who apparently police were called to the
house 39 times this is the new report
the police had gone to this guy's house
39 times and there was no involuntary
commitment of this person who apparently
when he was a child was even put in a
facility for violent juveniles right
obviously the system failed here but
what that has to do with gun control is
is a little bit beyond me
now folks on the left if they're really
honest they will say what they really
mean what they really mean is they want
to confiscate all the guns and so let's
talk about that in just a second whether
or not all the guns it should be
confiscated but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at bull and
branch so we're never going to agree on
everything when it comes to politics but
we can all agree on the need for a good
night's sleep so that we can all wake up
refreshed and ready to do battle in the
morning that's what bull and branch is
for you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills to get a
great night's sleep but you do need is
bull and branch sheets bowl and branch
sheets are just fantastic they are the
top-notch sheets okay you are paying
wholesale prices for luxury sheets
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in the store Bo and bran treats
are only a couple of hundred bucks that
are made from pure 100% organic cotton
which means every time you wash them
they actually gets softer they actually
get softer we actually discarded a lot
of our sheets after we got our first set
of bull and branch eats and then bought
a few more sets because they are just
that comfortable actually yeah I have a
tough time sleeping in sheets that are
not bowling pinch at this point right
now go to bowl and branch calm and use
promo code betting get $50 off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
calm promo club and the shipping is free
and you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them you can send them
back up for a refund but nobody that I
know has actually sent them back because
they are that good 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
calm that's bull and branch calm promote
code Ben Bo ll and branch comp Ramona
Ben again 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets and the promo clip Ben also lets
them know that we sent you as well okay
so there are some folks today who are
being a little bit more honest about
what it would take to really get to the
gun for utopia they want and that of
course is repeal of the Second Amendment
so Barry Weiss reporter over a staff
writer over
the New York Times who has ripped
earlier this week we talked about her
she was ripped earlier this week for
being supposedly too conservative for
saying that immigrants get the job done
after she did she tweeted that about the
daughter of immigrants rather than
immigrants themselves and she's ripped
up and down by members of the New York
Times staff
well she tweeted out repeal the Second
Amendment and then she tweeted out a
column that's written by Bret Stevens a
year ago in October of 2017 a few months
ago in October 2017 after the Las Vegas
shooting I believe and that column was
titled repealed the Second Amendment so
let's go through that column because
it's about as good an argument as you
will hear for repealing the Second
Amendment and it is not a very good
argument at that so Bret Stephen starts
off that column by joyriding what he
calls the conservative fetish for the
Second Amendment so why exactly would
conservatives support a private right to
own weapons for the protection of life
and liberty
after all Stephen says quote from a
law-and-order standpoint more guns mean
more murder now this actually is not
true him more guns in certain places
mean more murder more guns in Vermont do
not mean more murder more guns in rural
Texas do not necessarily mean more
murder
Stevens cites a study in the American
Journal of Public Health from 2013 to
show the quote states with higher rates
of gun ownership had disproportionately
large numbers of deaths from firearms
related homicides but there's only one
problem with the study this examines the
statistics on a state level which
doesn't make any sense given that
virtually all murder in the United
States takes place not on the rural not
in rural areas of states but in the big
cities and in those big cities there are
very harsh gun laws in the big cities
that's more nearly all murder in the
United States place in in big cities so
there's very little link actually
between state law and state homicide
rate as eugene pollock of the Washington
Post pointed out beyond that that same
study that he's citing that says that
states with higher rates of gun
ownership had disproportionately large
numbers of deaths from firearms related
homicide there's one problem with the
study the single largest variable when
it comes to murder rate is not actually
gun ownership in these various states
the single largest rate which the study
tries to bury the single largest problem
is that the the highest correlation is
between the number of black people in a
particular state and the number of
homicides this is not a racist point
okay people are not murdering other
people because they are black that's
obviously a stupid notion but if you're
gonna look at what is statistically
relevant and you're gonna look at
factors that are statistically relevant
the number of black per the number of
black people in a state are more
irrelevant than the number of guns in a
state right this is according to the
study quote for each one standard
deviation increase in proportion of
household gun ownership firearm homicide
rate increased by twelve point nine
percent for each one standard deviation
increase in population of black
population in proportion of black
population firearm homicide rate
increased by eighty two point eight
percent the study tried to bury that
data by not showing it in the actual
text of the study so if you love that
study so much then you should recognize
that there are variables that have
significantly more impact than gun
ownership rate and that has to do and we
can talk about why there's a higher
homicide rate in the black community
that there is in the white community a
lot of it has to do with under policing
the black community that has been a
matter of systemic discrimination since
the since the 1800s where white
communities basically said the black
communities fend for yourselves and
that's been inculcated in particular
areas of the culture but that's not the
point the point that I'm making is that
if you are going to suggest a gun
ownership is highly correlative with gun
death then you have to look at other
factors that are highly correlated with
gun death and see that these statistics
are not nearly as significant as you
think they are
Stevens continues by stating quote from
a personal safety standpoint more guns
means less safety he then cites the fact
that more people are killed every year
in accidental firearm death and in
self-defense shooting situations but
that's not a proper statistic either
because the times that people use a gun
in self-defense far exceed the number of
time actually shoot somebody to death in
self-defense the goal of having a gun in
your home is that you can pull it out I
mean I know there's a woman around the
corner and she was at home and there's a
guy who tried to break into her house
she went and got the shotgun from the
back room well rather she screamed the
guy ran away the police came they told
her what you should do next time that
happens is do you have a gun in the
house she said yes they said go get your
pump-action shotgun and then the
shotgun right give me the church do that
near the door and the guy will run you
want a problem now that would not show
up in any of the statistics that are
being measured by the CDC it would not
show up as a use of a gun in
self-defense because you didn't actually
point them to somebody didn't actually
shoot somebody didn't actually wound
somebody but this sort of stuff happens
all the time and there's a widely
varying set of statistics on how often
people use guns in self-defense this way
according to the national self-defense
survey extrapolations people use
firearms and self-defense millions of
times a year that may be too high
Bryan's already a reason has an
exhaustive analysis
of whether it's hundreds of thousands of
times a year or millions of times your
but it's certainly not 268 justify all
huh it's justifiable homicide by
firearms that is not the full measure of
the number of times people actually use
guns and self-defense in the United
States so Stephen then moves on to D
riding the philosophy of gun ownership
he says that the idea that we can
protect liberty by having guns in the
United States that we can protect from
foreign threat by having guns in the
United States is a quaint idea well I
wonder if it's such a quaint idea after
Afghanistan after Vietnam the fact is
that small arms gun ownership and
guerrilla warfare have been successful
at the warding some of the greatest
powers in the history of humanity the
United States in Afghanistan and Vietnam
and the Russians in Afghanistan for
example those have been thwarted by IEDs
and small guns these are not being
thwarted by necessarily top-level
military weaponry finally he goes on he
says that the idea that an armed
citizenry is the ultimate check on the
ambitions and encroachment of government
power is silly and then he says well
look at the Whiskey Rebellion that
wasn't a government check on it a check
on government power except that it sort
of was the Whiskey Rebellion which
happened in the late 1790s it was
directed at an internal whiskey tax
placed by the federal government there
are a bunch of people who grew corn for
whiskey and they were very upset that
the whiskey tax was affecting them and
there was an armed revolt and was put
down with violence a couple of people
were hung in it and so he says well that
that showed that it that there was a
failure of armed insurrection except for
the fact of course that President John
Adams may have lost the presidency in
1800 based on that and that President
Thomas Jefferson then immediately went
about revoking the whiskey tax so it
obviously had a pretty significant
political impact in fact you can even
look at today right there is a there's a
big hubbub over clive in bundy you
remember this there's nearly an armed
standoff with the federal government
over clive in bundy's territory where
clive in bundy wanted to feed his cattle
on land that he historically grazed
cattle on and the Environmental
Protection Association the EPA agency
rather they came in and they said that
this was terrible that he couldn't be
grazing his cattle on this area and they
tried to find him then they tried to
seize his farm then clive in bundy
refused to go along with the arrest and
a bunch of people showed up and refused
to along with the arrest as well well
there was just a jury nullification that
happened and cliven Bundy went free the
Bundy family went free and now there's
been a major political push in the
United States to get the EPA out of the
business of regulating so much land so
yes armed insurrection is not all
worth while sometimes it's terrible the
Civil War was a terrible terrible thing
but the idea that having lots of people
with guns does not somehow check the
ambitions of the federal government is
obviously nonsensical the reason that
we're not really talking in serious
terms about full-scale gun confiscation
is because you try that crap in Texas it
ain't gonna go well Stevens then turns
to the active shooter phenomenon he says
that such situations are extremely rare
in the rest of the world which is true
it is also true that they are extremely
rare here in the United States as well
so John lots website the Crime
Prevention Research Center he goes
through the annual death rate from mass
public shootings comparing the European
countries to us in Canada and he did it
on a per capita basis so one of the
things that happens is that the United
States is compared to Britain for
example they say oh there are lots more
shootings here than there are in Britain
right we're a much larger country than
Britain when you actually look at the
death rate per million people from mass
public shootings from 2009 through 2015
according the Crime Prevention Research
Center the number one country was Norway
because they had that horrible Andris
Brevik shooting and then it's Serbia
France Macedonia Albania Slovakia
Switzerland Finland Belgium Czech
Republic and then the United States
how about frequency I forget about the
number of dead how about frequency of
mass public shootings so if you look at
the frequency of mass public shootings
from January 2009 to December 2015
per million people in order it's
Macedonia Albania Serbia Switzerland
Norway Slovakia Finland Belgium Austria
Czech Republic France and then the
United States the average incident rate
for 28 EU countries is 0.06 0 - with a
95% confidence interval of zero point
zero two five seven two point zero nine
four seven seven in the u.s. rate is
point zero seven eight higher than the
EU rate but the US and average for EU
countries are not statistically
different in other words we're having
about the same number of mass shootings
as they're happening in other countries
and we have significantly more guns so
this idea that everything lines up is
just not statistically correct again the
case for full-scale gun confiscation is
particularly weak especially in a
country where you have as I say some 300
million guns and a hundred million gun
owners finally he says that leftists are
losing the gun control debate when they
lie about the facts which is true and
that they and that they should stop
talking about quote-unquote common-sense
gun control and they should just repeal
the Second Amendment
he says gun ownership shouldn't be
outlawed it doesn't need a blanket
constitutional protection
either right it never occurs to Stevens
that the fundamental argument in favor
of owning a gun is protection of life
which is the fundamental right that you
have in a state of nature according to
both the founding fathers and John Locke
and that the reason you have a gun is to
protect your own life and protect your
own Liberty and a state powerful enough
to confiscate weaponry on a grand scale
is a state powerful enough to end your
rights as well other rights not just
your First Amendment rights as stevens
finishes by saying the true foundation
of American exceptionalism should be our
capacity for moral and constitutional
renewal not our instinct for
self-destruction but that's not true at
all the true foundation of American
exceptionalism is the idea that we built
a system on unchanging human nature
human nature has not changed and the
idea of having a complete monopoly on
gun ownership over to the federal
government is a scary one or should be a
scary one to anyone who loves Liberty
okay when we continue here in just a
second I want to talk about the the NRA
because the left is going nuts over over
the NRA so let's talk about that okay
let's begin with Nancy Pelosi so Nancy
Pelosi of course has decided that the
NRA is fully corrupt and that they are
the ones deciding America's character
here is the house Minority Leader whose
political survival and this body is more
important than the survival of our
children for example most recently
yesterday Sandy Hook for example or on
the streets of our cities who of us and
here is more important whose political
survival is more important than that
nobody's nobody so we have to be bold we
have to go forward and we cannot let the
National Rifle Association and its many
however they get their money and that's
another subject to decide what the
character of America is yeah this sort
of Kabuki theater in which Democrats
participate is quite gross they did
control the Congress with 60 votes in
the Senate as well as a majority in the
House and the presidency from 2009 to
2011 and here is the grand total number
of major gun legislation pieces they
passed zero okay the answer is zero this
is what Democrats always do they don't
want to touch these issues because they
think their political winners instead
they wish them to fester if Democrats
really thought the gun confiscation were
a thing they could have moved in favor
of it in 2010 in 2009 into the
they didn't do any of those things
instead they sat around and waited for
Republicans to take office again and
then they rail against the Republicans
supposedly being in the pay of the NRA
they did the same thing with illegal
immigration we'll get to that in a
little while Democrats have been saying
that illegal immigration daca deeply
important things didn't do anything on
illegal immigration while they had
control and now the Republicans have
controlled they're railing against
Republicans this is the game they play
but I want to go to a core view that
she's talking about here and it was
repeated across the media that the NRA
is in control of our politics that the
reason that we haven't had a vast gun
confiscation or new gun laws passed is
because of the evils of the NRA which is
paying people off
MSNBC's Stephanie ruhle said the same
thing she suggested that it's just
because Republicans are being paid off
by the NRA President Trump tweeted his
prayers adding no child teacher or
anyone else should ever feel unsafe in
an American school well the NRA spent
more than 21 million dollars supporting
President Trump in his 2016 election
almost 10 million dollars in ads and
other pro Trump material and 12 million
bucks attacking Hillary Clinton the
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims the dollars and cents are
another story yeah so the the idea again
is that the NRA is responsible for
everything bad happening in Congress
because didn't paying people off Jimmy
Kimmel said the same thing last night he
had said that the that the NRA had
Congress's balls in a money clip which
is just absurd last night he said
somewhere along these line along the
line these guys forgot they work for us
not the NRA us and this time we're not
gonna allow you to bow your head and
prayer for two weeks until you get it
all clear and you move on to the next
thing we're gonna make sure you do
something this time well no you're not
because the vast majority of the public
is not in favor of the do something
mentality the vast majority of the
public is in favor of perhaps some
measures that would do something here
but you have to name the measures but
let's discuss the underlying claim Rob
Reiner did the same thing he said there
are 21 million reasons why Donald Trump
refuses to protect our children from
being slaughtered by guns the NRA has
deep pockets but we will show them that
our hearts and our pockets are deeper
than theirs our hearts Reich the NRA is
heartless because it says that ball
abiding citizens should own guns you
think the NRA is in favor of these
school shootings you think the NRA wants
these things to happen you think the NRA
is indifferent to all of this and when
we last had a major shooting which was
after that after that church shooting in
Texas when the guy who put down the
shooter was an NRA mm
the media conveniently ignored all that
who's an NRA instructor because in in
their crusade to make it seem that the
NRA wants to get hands and guns in the
hands of bad people they ignore the fact
that the NRA ensures that good people
can have their hands on guns but this
money point is so stupid that Donald
Trump is only pro NRA because the NRA I
spent some 21 million dollars on the on
the Trump election cycle
you know much money was spent in that
election cycle like a billion dollars
was spent in that election cycle they
did the same thing Stephanie ruhle did
the same thing by the way with with Rob
Portman in Ohio she said that in the
last 30 years Rob Portman received some
three million dollars from the NRA Rob
Portman in his last senatorial race
spent 30 million dollars so the amount
of money he's received from the NRA is
not 10 percent to what he spent on one
election cycle and this is true across
the board okay so how much money does
the NRA actually spend first of all the
NRA spent approximately 13 million
dollars on all candidates between 1998
and 2016 13 million okay that is
according to PolitiFact that is not
according to me that's PolitiFact the
left's favorite fact checker the NRA I
spend money on outside expenditures this
would be their own PACs and spending
money on ads in the amount of one
hundred and forty four point three
million plus another forty five point
nine million on lobbying which is a
grand total of two hundred and 3.2
million on political activities over 18
years or approximately twenty two point
six million dollars per two year
election cycle the NRA does spend a lot
more during presidential election cycles
according to open secrets the NRA spent
some fifty four million dollars on
twenty two in 2016 on politics that
would be on issue ads across the country
that be unloving that would be an
organizing all the rest so that sounds
like a lot of money right fifty four
point four million dollars in 2016 on
politics and they really are the
entirety of the gun lobby
hey so-called gun lobby is basically the
NRA there are a few other organizations
like the Gun Owners of America but those
are much smaller organizations so let's
look at some other segments of politics
and where money gets spent so according
to the National Institute for Labor
Relations Research how much did labor
unions spend in 2016 alone they spent
one point seven one three billion
billion dollars on pallulah
political activities in lobbying for
2016 alone so the NRA I spent 50 million
and the labor unions spent one point
seven three to seven one three billion
billion okay that means that they spent
like three percent of what the
what the labor unions spent that's an
insane number but it doesn't matter
they're gonna continue to proclaim that
the NRA is those powerful force in
politics it's also interesting the
unions spend this much money you never
hear about the idea that these that
these Democrats are being paid off by
the unions that the unions are paying
off Democrats in corrupt fashion there's
a lot more evidence of that and there is
that the the Republicans are being paid
off by the NRA the Republicans are being
elected by the NRA to to presumably be
pro-gun but they were pro-gun before the
NRA was there if the NRA I disappeared
overnight there'd be five million donors
who join another a gun organization and
that gunner organization would be
lobbying when it comes to the unions
it's a different story unions are very
often in the business of giving money
directly to candidates and then sitting
there and actually making deals with the
candidates for their union members which
seems a lot more corrupt to me how about
play about the abortion industry in 2016
2008 between
sorry 2012 and 2016 Planned Parenthood
spent 34 million dollars on outside
spending according to open secrets
emily's list another abortion group
spent thirty three point two million
dollars in 2016 alone
so the abortion Lobby is spending about
as much as the gun lobby but you never
hear that Planned Parenthood is paying
off the Democrats in rear the Emily list
is paying off the Democrats group spend
a lot of money but the notion that the
NRA is disproportionately buying
politicians it's just not factually true
which brings us to a deeper question do
these outside groups actually buy
politicians or are they simply backing
politicians who already support their
agenda you have to show the politician
who switched his position from anti-gun
to pro-gun after the NRA jumped in
Donald Trump knew that the American
public and particularly Republican
primary voters we're not gonna stand for
an anti-gun position in shift for the
NRA money but it's always easy to have
this this ridiculous theory there's
someone out there some evil nefarious
force who's spreading money in the back
room and that's why and that's why gun
control hasn't prospered the reason gun
control has not prosper in the United
States is because it's deeply unpopular
when you come down to the specifics that
is why it is not because of NRA money
the NRA is popular because people don't
want large-scale gun control it's not
that people don't want large-scale gun
control because the NRA has lots of
money
it's a Miss read of the situation on a
grand scale folks for all the talk about
gun control in a piece of breaking news
from The Wall Street Journal the FBI has
now said it mistakenly
investigate a credible and specific tip
about the teenager charged with storming
into the florida high school and killing
17 people in a statement the FBI said it
received a call on a tip line from a
person close to the shooter the caller
provided information on quote his gun
ownership desire to kill people erratic
behavior disturbing social media posts
as well as the potential of him
conducting a school shooting the
information should have been assessed as
a potential threat to life it was not
forwarded for investigations leave me at
the FBI's Miami field office and no
further investigation was conducted so
well done FBI for all the talk about how
the government is necessary in order to
remove guns from 300 million via for 300
million guns in American society removed
guns from a hundred million people
across the country the FBI can't even
track down one damn lead that says
everything you need to know about the
guy who went in and shot up a school you
know talk about government malfeasance
and government incompetence start there
you know talk about helping to solve
this problem
start with the government actually
following its own rules start the
governor actually doing what it's
supposed to do the government sucks at
everything they prove it once again and
the idea that I'm gonna hand over my gun
to this government they're gonna protect
me you have got to be kidding me
okay in just a second we're gonna talk
about immigration proposals that happen
yesterday plus the president doing some
serious King David Inge in a little
while but first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley we're calm and subscribe
when you go over to Daley wire.com for
$9.99 a month you get the rest of the
show live you get the rest of the Andrew
Klavan show live the rest of Michael
Noel's show live he gives me part of our
mailbag today send us a letter we'll
read it you also can ask us live mailbag
questions over at Daily wire comm if you
want all of those things Plus this the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr that
is $99 a year for the annual
subscription you will enjoy it you will
love it you'll live it it is fantastic
you just want to listen later for free
iTunes SoundCloud Apple podcasts any of
the apps have our podcast please leave
us a review we always appreciate it and
subscribe over at YouTube we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
already so I just want to give you the
brief update on what happens on
immigration so March 5th is when daca is
supposed to expire daca that is when
supposedly deportations begin for people
who have not registered through the daca
system or when deportations could begin
for even those who have registered
through it with the government through
the daca system that's not actually
gonna happen in all reality not much is
gonna change on March 5th except that
people will not be given new work
permits essentially in the United States
if they are illegal immigrants there are
four bills that were brought up
yesterday in the Senate all of them died
they were all dead on arrival because
Democrats are not willing to compromise
on these issues so here are the bills
there was the John McCain Chris Coons
bill that was touted as a moderate
reform measure and never made it out of
debate that was that that basically was
a was a proposal to give permanent
residents to permanent residents to
recipients of daca immigration program
in return for 110 million dollar annual
grant for increased border security it
specifically excluded any funding for
construction of a wall on the southern
border that one did not make it out of
committee
second proposals Pat Toomey's proposal
from Pennsylvania Republican that he
proposed that the u.s. cut off funding
for sanctuary cities in sanctuary states
like California until those cities and
states agreed to share current
information with federal immigration
authorities according to Emily Zanotti
over at Daily wire 54 senators voted to
put that bill to a full Senate vote but
to me couldn't get any bipartisan
support and it died in debate and then
there were two more proposals that
actually came up for a formal vote the
final two proposals were dueling
agreements on daca and the border wall
one was from the White House and when we
were from senators Mike rounds
Republican from South Dakota and senator
angus King independent from a buddies
really a democratic caucuses with the
Democrats the bill traded a path to
citizenship for daca recipients for
border enforcement and even 25 billion
dollars for southern border security
construction projects but it included a
conditional amnesty for daca parents and
it was popular among members of both
parties but 54 senators only voted for
the bill because Trump came out and said
that he was not in favor of the bill the
White House had called it a blanket
amnesty and refused to take part in the
groups negotiations well so there is Ted
Cruz yesterday ripping into the rounds
bill suggesting that it was simply too
weak so you don't even like the
president's four pillars listen that is
dramatically to the left of where Barack
Obama was Barack Obama and
which was executive amnesty it was
illegal it was unconstitutional daca
covered six hundred and ninety thousand
people why on earth are Republicans
trying to more than double nearly triple
that for physics undergraduate now it's
a more accurate ain't no it's a more
accurate number you know tell that to
the steel workers tell that to the truck
drivers tell that to the American people
we promised we wouldn't do amnesty
so basically Trump turned against a lot
of his own proposal after his base
didn't like it which is fully
predictable
the white house bill was presented by
Chuck Grassley that bill included a path
to citizenship for daca recipients
conditioned on twenty five billion
dollars in financial support for a
border wall Grassley's bill did make it
to the floor but even Republicans were
reticent to vote for the deal and it
failed thirty-nine to sixty so that
means that nothing has gone forward here
Democrats did not vote with Republicans
in order to pass the 60-vote threshold
they were given a vote and they voted
against both of those proposals so yes a
lot of Republicans voted against Trump's
proposal but Democrats should have
universally voted for those proposals if
they thought that it was gonna stand the
rounds bill got a vote they got 54 votes
in fact but the Democrats were not
willing to allow it to go to a full vote
right there was a filibuster that was in
place so they needed 60 so well done
Democrats not compromising once again
Trump did blame the Democrats for this
of course but yeah his leadership on
this was was less than stellar shall we
say but he did prove by the way that the
Democrats were not fully control a
matter because Democrats had nothing to
lose here anyway Democrats were always
willing to let Trump go all the way down
the line then reinstate daca informally
they're fine with that they want to make
Republicans look both heartless and
incompetent and they will succeed
probably in that task okay time for a
quick Trump investigation update or or
Trump scandal update so a couple of
stories out today one stormy Daniels the
porn star who says that she had sex with
Trump she says that she kept the dress
that she had on when she was being
nailed by Trump and so she still has all
of his DNA on it I didn't know this was
a thing by the way like apparently
Monica Lewinsky do this and now stormy
Daniels - this is the thing that if you
have sex with a famous dude that you get
to that you keep the clothing very weird
thing I've never had never heard of
anything like this except apparently it
seems to be happening a lot that is one
story other story is that apparently the
National Enquirer spent 150 thousand
dollars on a story about Trump having an
affair with a Playboy Playmates this is
well he was
marrieds Milania who is being cooked so
often it makes your head swim and she
was cheating on her repeatedly of course
not a shock and apparently the National
Enquirer because the editor over there
is friends with Trump bought the story
and then buried the story which of
course is not shocking either the
woman's name is a mcdougal Katherine
mcdougal I believe and a Karen McDougal
Karen McDougal so Karen McDougal was a
Playboy Playmate she had an affair with
Trump and she has a long series of
contemporaneous diary notes that suggest
that this was happening of course the
White House says this didn't happen
that's not true of course it probably
did happen a lot of King David in going
on a lot of people out there and in in
religious land saying well he's just
like King David no he's not just like
King David the whole point of King David
is that he repented there is no
repentance here yuck
okay time for some things I like things
I hate in the mailbag so things I like
so this was Valentine's Day week so as
Valentine's week so here is what many
people consider to be the Rome the most
romantic theme in the history of modern
music this of course is Sergei
Rachmaninoff's Rhapsody on a theme of
Paganini
[Music]
okay so there it is that's used most for
most frequently here of this because of
the movie somewhere in time which was
which started Christopher Reeve back in
1980 was a big hit at the time so it's
worth listening to the whole piece it's
actually a really great piece the
Rhapsody other theme of Paganini the
romantic theme is only about two and a
half minutes of that okay time for a
couple of quick things that I hate so
number one University of Minnesota I'm
supposed to speak there week after next
and they have apparently exiled me to a
building off campus for safety reasons
it's like a 400 500 seater as opposed to
the 1500 seater that was requested they
are having a simultaneous event on the
main campus the University of Minnesota
sponsored by the Women's Center about
anti racism in the era of Trump because
I was apparently a Trump supporter and a
racist
I am neither of course so that was weird
but they're having that in the middle of
the campus it's apparently no safety
concerns when lefties are holding a
counter event to my event but serious
safety concerns when I hold my event
which means I have to be exiled
once again demonstrating the hecklers
veto in full effect speaking of the
hecklers veto my friend steven crowder
apparently has now been banned from
DePaul University so just like I've been
banned he and I both been banned from
DePaul University and he was supposed to
do an event there and they preemptively
ban him they've said that his comedy
videos are obviously intended to demean
and insult which if you've ever seen
Stephens show is true because he's a
comedian I can name a comedian who did
not demean an insult and I will name you
a not very funny comedian so Stephens
been banned from DePaul University so
congratulations to Steven on joining the
list of those of us who can no longer
travel to that great University okay
final thing that I hate so LeBron James
went after President Trump yesterday and
said the president Trump doesn't give a
bleep about the people this prompted
Laura Ingraham to go on a on a diatribe
against LeBron James hearing here's what
LeBron James had to say straight oh how
do you describe the climate for an
athlete with the platform out
that want to talk about what's happening
at home world what a climate is hot the
number one job in America the point of
person is someone who doesn't understand
the people and really don't give a
goodbye the people when I was growing up
they were like three jobs that you look
for inspiration or you felt like these
were the people that can give me life it
was the president United States it was
whoever was the best in sports and then
it was like the greatest musician at the
time you never thought you can be them
but you can grab inspiration from I felt
like I can be you know it was a
neighborhood african-american cop and he
was cool as he'll come around
you get awful I could be him I could be
him but I never felt I could be the
president knighted States but I grabbed
inspiration from that and this time
right now with the President of the
United States it's at a bad time
and while we cannot change what comes
out of that man's mouth we can continue
to alert the people that watch us they
listen to us as this is not the way
no listen LeBron has every ability to
speak out about these things and he's
obviously got a big platform and people
listen to what he said what he says I
don't think it makes him a political
expert by any stretch of the imagination
when he points out that the president
has not done a good job of connecting
with a lot of people in the United
States this is obviously true during the
election cycle it was true after the
election cycle so there's some truth to
this I'm not as a as a general rule in
favor of people who have not spent a
fair bit of time studying politics
speaking with authority about politics I
will say that what LeBron is saying here
there's an element of truth to what
LeBron is saying here with regard to the
president's capacity to reach out to
people he needs to do a better job of
reaching out to people but it would help
if people would also reach out to the
president meaning if LeBron reached out
to trump and said you know I want to
start a dialogue with you I think that'd
be more useful than him sitting there
and griping about Trump per se although
listen he has every right to do it okay
time for some mailbag stuff okay you
know one more final thing that I hate I
would urge everybody to go back a couple
of days ago I did I did a long monologue
about Black Panther which I've not seen
yet I'm looking forward to seeing it
this weekend I hope if I have time and
and then I want to give you my my honest
opinion about it the entire monologue
was critiquing the media's response to
Black Panther suggesting because the
was basically suggesting this his end of
world right this was the most important
thing that has ever happened to the
black community according to members of
the New York Times there are two
separate major op-eds in the New York
Times about the importance of Black
Panther as a cultural moment and all of
this that's what I was ripping it's
being taken out of context in Kathy
Newman hey Kathy Newman was the person
who interviewed Jordan Peterson and just
kept retwisting what Jordan Peterson was
saying is being Kathy Newman go back and
watch the original monologue you'll see
exactly what I meant what I was talking
about specifically was that I don't
believe that people should get deeply
excited about racial solidarity issues I
think racial solidarity is a mistake
whatever the race I think that religious
salad area is one thing philosophical
solidarity is one thing but racial
solidarity is is generally a tribal
affiliation that I'm not fond of and I'm
the media portraying this is the essays
a major massive cultural moment I
thought was wildly overblown as I said a
couple of days ago that was the main
point of that to go back and watch it if
you don't believe me okay time for some
mailbag entries so David says hi Ben I
listened to your analysis of the school
shooting yesterday I grew their insights
are you aware of any objective Studies
on causation of mass shootings that
study societal factors in addition to
gun laws for example single-parent homes
violence in movies and videogames social
media secular culture etc mental health
is often cited as well if there has been
a significant deterioration in mental
health and what is driving that I'd be
interested in your perspectives - well I
don't think there's been a significant
deterioration of mental health by
statistics although more Americans are
now on antidepressants than at any time
in American history by a fairly
significant margin the the problem is
that whenever you look at these
shootings and then there's Studies about
the shootings the sample size is simply
too small there are not enough mass
shootings for you to gather any sort of
trend line other than a rough trend line
so what we can see is that a huge number
of these mass shootings involve people
who are deeply mentally ill and about
whom there were red flags so if there is
an increase in school shootings I'm not
sure that you can attribute that to
greater rise in the number of people who
are mentally ill in the United States
but you may be able to say that where we
should be looking if we want to stop
school shootings is among people who are
severely mentally ill or schizophrenic
for example violent schizophrenic
seasonal skits for extra violent and
people who have evidenced threats
against neighbors people who have acted
oddly in other words look for red flags
the question is what's the goal of the
study is the goal of the study is to
suggest measures by which we stop mass
shootings then we ought to be looking
at what best fits the trendline as
opposed to broad societal trends because
let's say that it were single motherhood
for example that core single motherhood
does correlate highly with with general
crime but it doesn't correlate as highly
with mass shootings for example Trey
Martin says hey Ben I read an article
this week in a major newspaper that
showed how historically all countries
have utilized some form of trade
protectionism including the u.s. in its
early stages my question is if all
countries do this and in particular
since China is doing is how can we
realistically keep our competitive lead
if we and only we insist on a purist
approach to free trade well the way that
you keep your competitive lead is
through a purist approach to free trade
means that all the inputs in your
industry are cheaper so let's say for
example that we put no tariffs on
anything but China tariffs the crap out
of our products they are taxing their
own citizens and let's say they taxed
their own citizens to dump all of that
money into steel undercutting our
domestic steel industry which is kind of
what's happening ok let's it they do
that so now steel is cheaper on the
American market so that means that
American auto manufacturers are using
that steel to make products cheaper than
they will be able to make those products
in China in other words protectionism is
almost universally linked with subsidies
to a particular industry subsidies to a
particular industry mean taking from one
potential industry and giving to another
potential industry it means you are
taking China is taking money from an
industry that would thrive on free trade
and is instead giving that money to an
industry that does not thrive on free
trade namely the steel industry for
example well that's not good for China
may be good for trying to steel industry
it's not good for China's overall
economy what is better for an overall
economy is to take cheap inputs and use
that to make the most competitive
products and then out-compete people
despite terrifying by the way if you
tariff your own country if you raise
tariffs to at a high level that does not
make your country stronger it makes your
country weaker then you take this to its
logical extreme if you tariffs to
everything at a hundred percent in the
United States meaning that everything
you buy had to come from the United
States we would all be significantly
poorer because we'd all have to spend a
lot more money on products we are used
to getting for cheap that would not
forward competition it would not forward
style of life it would not make your
life better
josh has dear Ben do you feel
conservatives are gaining ground in US
culture
what are your barometers for measuring
cultural chefs I do think conservatives
are gaining ground in US culture you can
see it particularly on issues like
abortion and I think a lot of that is
because of the fragmentation of media
the fact that the media is no longer
controlled top-down the fact that there
are literally hundreds of thousands and
millions of people who engage with the
show every single day we have like a
million peep
engage with this show everyday and
there's no gatekeeper and if you want to
watch the show you watch the show it's
not that there was somebody got a green
light me over to network that
demonstrates I think the cultural shift
and it's happening in entertainment
terms as well fewer people going out to
see the the media approved movies more
people staying home and watching what
they want to watch taking movies the
warrant hits and making them hits on the
back end is really it's really
fascinating to watch Eric says do you
think the government needs to diversify
from a two-party system well I'm not
sure it's a matter of the government
diversifying I think the American people
might be better served by more parties
unfortunately the system tends to favor
a two-party binary system now the thing
in favor of the two-party binary system
is it creates a certain level of
stability
usually in multi-party systems those are
usually linked with parliamentary
systems where you need a majority to
govern the minute there's not a majority
to govern no coalition to govern then
everything falls apart you have to have
a new election this creates tremendous
instability in these systems and it
means that it's very hard to get
anything done yeah there's there's a
fair bit of gridlock particularly around
dismantling social programs for example
because there's so many particular
interests represented so their their
costs and benefits is what I would say
there
Panagiotis is that house pronounced
Haven I'm a high school student in
Canada and most of my political
education is colored by certain point of
view could you explain to me what a
right-wing dictator would look like is
there credence to the idea that Hitler
was a right-wing or okay so in order to
explain what a right-wing dictator would
look like you have to distinguish
between the right-wing in Europe and the
right-wing in the United States so
conservatism in the United States it
makes it it is impossible for there to
be a conservative dictator in the United
States because conservatism is
essentially classical liberalism meaning
small government is baked into the cake
you could theoretically have a dictator
who said I'm not gonna control
everything and right-wing dictator would
look like a minimalist King maybe and
somebody who says go about your daily
business and I'm just here to make sure
that you don't kill each other that's
what a conservative dictator would look
like but it's it's very difficult to
think of that actually happening because
typically in monarchies the idea of a
small government monarchy is
extraordinarily rare it's in fact I
can't name a single instance in which
that has happened
usually when people say right-wing
dictator they really mean people who are
anti-communist so Hitler was considered
anti-communist and whose right wing when
you compared him to the left in Germany
the left in Germany was communist but
Hitler's policies were fully in favor of
national healthcare his policies were
fully in favor of gun
Asians and I think that the the basic
gap between how politics works in Europe
and how politics works in the United
States there's a serious lack of
classical liberalism in Europe their
American conservatism is based on
classical liberalism so what's defined
as right-wing in Europe is basically
anything that's anti-communist even if
those people are in some parts of their
program socialist so by American
standards Hitler was not a conservative
by run by German standards Hitler was a
right-winger and he allied with
right-wingers in his government Patrick
says LeBron talked about people who
inspired him who were people that
inspired you in politics culture
athletics etc so in politics I can have
a lot of people in politics I was always
into history it was usually historical
figures I was usually John Adams or
Winston Churchill or Abraham Lincoln
growing up I didn't have sports posters
on my wall I had a giant poster of
Abraham Lincoln on my wall at home I had
a poster with all the presidents on my
wall at home those were the things that
that I always found inspiration or were
ideas and people who represented those
ideas Moses obviously if you're Jew so I
never found tremendous inspiration from
cultural figures they're people who I've
found inspiring just an artistic level
so I still find roger federer for
example inspiring at an artistic level
just somebody who is the best at what
he's done he's the best ever at what
he's done that's an inspiring thing if
I'm om Beethoven is inspiring in the
sense that he is the pinnacle of human
achievement these things are inspiring
but not in terms of I get my moral code
or my moral ideas from those folks let's
see Walter says what are the best
defenses for fiscally conservative
policies suppose I was talking to
someone who said and said that snap or
WIC which are these are programs to
support women and infant children is a
small cost for the taxpayer that it
isn't worth touching and if we want to
lower the amount of money we spend on it
we're evil people who don't care about
the poor etc well the question is not
the amount of money that you are handing
to people who are on food stamps the
question is do those food stamps
enervate a population one of the reasons
to have work requirements for all of
this is to create an incentive scheme
whereby you are getting people off of
food stamps the goal of food stamps
should be not just a feed people to get
people off of food stamps the goal of
welfare should be to get people off of
welfare in other words make a plan and
the system should be responsive to the
plan that you make so that it's not a
permanent handout it is in fact a hands
up if you're gonna have these programs
at all this is why I think private
charity is much better because
if you are face to face with someone you
said want some of your money that person
it's a lot easier for that person to say
why do you deserve my money and then you
actually have to come up with a plan for
success if you have a nameless faceless
system that hands you a check every
month very often that is going to
actually create an incentive for you not
to have a plan because that check is
just gonna be there no matter what when
Charlie's has been small fan I'm only
five six simply wanting to know your top
five comedy films from the 90s and
2000's ooh
from the 90s and 2000's is a little too
narrow for me cuz I don't think there
have been a lot of great comedies in the
90s and 2000's best comedy films ever I
mean twits he definitely has to be on
the list and that was like 1984
maybe 1983 liar liar' I think is really
funny Tommy Boy is my guilty pleasure I
think that movie is insanely funny I'm
not a fan of a lot of the modern
comedies actually airplane is great
comedy obviously there's some that are
that are less funny than they are my
Groundhog Day is not like the super
funniest movie but it's a very good
movie one of my favorite comedies
growing up was the court jester which
comes from the 1950s because it's all
just cleverness and wordplay Zoolander
if you're gonna ever heal modern comedy
Zoolander is really funny but again it's
stupid funny Meet the Parents stupid
funny those are those are probably the
ones that they come immediately to mine
but I actually tend to favor older
comedies over newer comedies and some
that are kind of obscure this one called
Ruggles of read gap with Charles
what's-his-name now man I'm losing my
mind
Ruggles of I'm gonna look it up because
otherwise I'm gonna go absolutely insane
Ruggles of read gap is with Charles
Laughton and that is from 1935 and
that's that's a really good movie that's
he Benton says dear Ben my name is James
Tyler and I've had the pleasure of
becoming a first-time dad my wife and I
love our daughter very much I'm
wondering at what age it's okay to start
introducing your shoulder into political
ideals I would like to start sooner and
my wife would like to start later even
though you don't become president making
this a moot point is everybody would
become Republican at what age is it
appropriate to start teaching your
daughter moral views of politics and
what age should you talk to your
children about it I don't think it's
even a matter of teaching your kid about
tax rates I think it's a matter of
teaching your kids about values people
ask how did I get so conservative at
such a young age and what I usually say
is that I grew up with a certain set of
values that are innately conservative
personal responsibility you have to
clean up your room you're responsible
for your
you have to work hard if you do work
hard I think that things will come to
you if you don't work hard then bad
things will probably happen to you the
decisions have consequences that what
you do is up to you that you are an
individual they're not beholden to any
group that wants to make about that you
have to be moral regardless of what
other people in your class are doing
these are values and I'm sure your wife
would probably agree these are values
that actually have to be inculcated
essentially from the time the kids are
born those actually have political
ramifications the separation between
politics and values is the death of
civilization Matz has been I recently
heard a friend of mine who was majoring
in English education talking about how
one of her classes was teaching about
how there is no proper English and that
it is racist and oppressive to correct
grammar and pronunciation specifically
of black students speaking in Ebonics
what do you say to someone who claims
that any language is proper as long as
it gets the point across that's stupid
that's what I say to that if there is
proper use of language just like there's
proper use of mathematics mathematics is
a language those rules can change over
time there are ways of communicating
that do not involve proper English that
is still a form of communication but
this is like the folks who say there's
no such thing as good art and bad art
yes there are things such as good are
better and there are elements of
sentences like verbs nouns and
adjectives and if you use them
interchangeably your sentence makes no
sense so even folks who believe that
Ebonics is sort of traditional English
they're equivalent even those people
would acknowledge that there are certain
ways that words are used in sentences
that if you use them in different ways
that sentence would make no sense well
there are other rules as well and those
those rules include how to spell words
they include how to pronounce words they
include they include how sentences are
constructed and paragraphs are
constructed and there is a better
English and there is a worse English and
there are different forms of English but
if you want to proclaim that all forms
of English are equivalent that's really
really dumb I mean it is not the same as
English Ebonics it's not the same as
English if it is used
you know either either it is a either it
is a different form of English that is
not as proper in the sense of you know
actually abiding by the normal rules of
English or it is a separate language
entirely which is set what some Ebonics
advocates suggest andrew says what are
your thoughts on the Benjamin Netanyahu
corruption allegations I like him but
this seems rather serious on face value
it's a little bit hard to tell honestly
because some of the people who are
making the allegations are his political
opponents one of the people testifying
against him is yeah or Lapita guy who
could become Prime Minister if Netanyahu
is a stood also it seems that so I think
I read
Kalon this the other day on the air
about the corruption allegations it
seems that all the things that he was
supposedly promising and return never
materialized so it's hard to say there
was bribery when nothing materialized on
the other end even says do you subscribe
to the milton friedman monetarism theory
or the Austrian school of thought would
you abolish the Federal Reserve I am of
the Viennese the the Austrian school of
thought when it comes to monetary policy
I don't believe that the Federal Reserve
is a necessary component to a
functioning banking system when George
says hi Ben would you be able to clarify
whether Ronald Reagan was as successful
economically as those on the red
claiming was I have a friend who claims
Reagan's economic policies tanked the
economy is this true no Reagan's
economic policies led to the largest
peacetime growth in American history the
the growth of the 1990s was largely an
aftereffect of the growth of the 1980s
and you can see that because you can see
how the economy was contracting up till
about 1983 when it turned around okay
final one this is a tough one okay Ben
says I have a question regarding
homosexuality I struggle with unwanted
same-sex attraction but I'm still
attracted to the opposite sex
what I really want for my life is to
have a wife and children but I feared
this would get in my way one day what
advice can you give me for this and I'm
curious to ask how do people of the
Jewish faith and community handle
homosexuality and people who have
unwanted same-sex attraction well I mean
the way that we handle unwanted same-sex
attraction would be the same way that
you handle unwanted sexual attraction to
people who are not your wife meaning
that attraction is something that we all
have to struggle with attraction to
things that we can't have or that we may
be morally opposed that's something that
we all struggle with on on a real basis
that doesn't mean all those struggles
are equivalent obviously if you have
same-sex attraction that's not
equivalent in in kind to me having
struggles with being attracted to women
who are not my wife for example as every
man does write every single per every
single man is built for polygamy and
every single man who has moral aims
toward monogamy um but the the idea here
is the behavior and attraction are two
separate things and I'm not going to
make light of the struggles that
somebody has with attraction do I think
that homosexuality is necessarily
entirely genetic note so I think some of
its environmental probably do I think
that it's a reality of course it's in
reality how you choose to deal with it
obviously is your individual choice in a
free country but if you want to have a
wife and you want to have kids then I
would recommend that you keep away from
situations in which you would be tempted
to act on attraction again the same
that I give to men who don't want to
have an affair stay away from situations
where you'd be tempted to act on an
attraction stay away from things that
attract you if it's something that
bothers you and if that's the way that
you want to live your life okay so we
will be back here on Monday with much
much more I am sure I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing